Sam Richardson
[Music]
Sam so much to talk about first of all I
want to clear up something that is not
an affectation that okay no okay yes
that would make you a real [ __ ] I'm
coming out on Conan with a cane you I'm
told you had knee surgery I did I had
knee surgery like about like a week and
a half what two weeks ago mm-hmm like
Thursday was it what was the problem I
tore my meniscus at the gym doing
barbell squats so like I went down I
heard a pop and it's like oh that's
proud yeah and irulu yeah but then I had
the surgery you two weeks ago and like I
went to see Avengers like that night cuz
I see Avengers the night that you the
same day that you had surgery that was
the same day it was opening I wasn't
gonna have spoilers like ruin it for me
so I got when they're in crutches and
like on vicodin just like yeah intense
that's how seriously you take your
Avengers screening very very seriously
like all like nerd dumb if you say
you're like superhero stuff like Marvel
stuff I get my house I upset it's like
full of what do you have what level of
nerd them are we talking about let's see
like even just like today I got a Thor
hammer
[Music]
that response you've got a Thor hammer
and it arrived today arrived today is
like it's like you can talk to it it
says nice things back to you I was gonna
say you can talk to anything Captain
America shield I have like a higher man
helmet I've got I like how the Woo's are
trickling I know I even have a Captain
America massage chair in my house what
is it what is that Captain America they
make a Captain America massage chair I
guess so they clearly here with you own
one yeah if they played massage chair
that's like Captain America themed I was
like going to buy real furniture for my
home and I like spice like it's massage
chair place sounds like I'll just go
peek and I went in and there was like
this Captain America the massage chair
no well I've got to no no you didn't
have to I think we have a picture of the
massage chair that is
I was ready to laugh at it that look
that's a good-looking chair good yeah
getting a massage and channeling Captain
America at the same time and it works
I'll tell you it's like Steve Rogers is
like working on you with his like super
soldier hands back there all right well
I lost you a man yeah you went too far
take your cane
[Laughter]